>> All right, Tim, can you introduce your
company and your products?
>> MOORE: My name is Tim Moore. I work at
a company called Atlassian. We develop productivity
tools for technical teams. Best known product
is probably JIRA, which is an issue tracker,
a place to track your bugs or support issues
or anything like that. We also have a product
called Confluence, which is our Enterprise
Wiki. You can use it for documentation, for
requirements planning, really for any kind
of collaborative document management. We also
have a series of other development tools.
The one is called FishEye. That's for source
code repository management and exploration.
We got one called Crucible, which is for source
code review. One called Crowd, which is a
single-sign on tool. One called Clover, which
is a test coverage tool so that you can test--you
can track the metrics of how well your tests
are actually testing your code. And, Bamboo,
which is a continuous integration server for
forming builds. The company is based on Australia.
It's been around 2002. But we also have offices
in San Francisco and Amsterdam. And, I work
in the San Francisco office as a developer
for about the last 18 months.
>> All right. What Google technologies do
you use?
>> MOORE: Mostly we're using OpenSocial. So,
we're making a real big push now to take OpenSocial,
which has already sort of proven itself as
a social networking technology, and we're
using Enterprise because we've decided that
development and really all kinds of business
activities are inherently social activities.
So what works well for social networks also
works really well for Enterprise applications.
>> Right. What was involved in your decision
to use the OpenSocial platform?
>> MOORE: Well, a lot of it is that JIRA,
our issue tracking tool, has a configurable
dashboard that can be used to display data
about your issues. We thought it would be
even better if we could display data from
the other products that we sell, and even
other products that we don't sell, side by
side with your issue information. And we look
at iGoogle and saw how that was able to pull
content from lots of different developers,
put them all in one place and display that
information next to each other and said, "Wouldn't
it be cool if dev tools work this way?" And,
you could pull your issues and your source
code activity and code review activity and
your builds all into a single unified dashboard.
And when we saw that OpenSocial was based
off of Google Gadgets, we thought that this
would be the ideal technology to build our
new dashboards off of it. And the more we
thought about it, the more we thought that
we could bring in other aspects of OpenSocial
as well because, you know, if you think about
a Wiki, it's really kind of a social network,
if you think about source code repository,
the different committers to that project are,
in a way, members of a social network.
>> Have been there any major challenges that
you've encountered on the platform?
>> MOORE: I think the biggest challenge that
we've had is that, a lot of what OpenSocial
was built for was websites that have a single
company controlling them with whatever deployment
architecture they need. Whereas we sell package
software that's mostly installed by our customers
on their own servers behind their firewalls.
And OpenSocial wasn't necessarily designed
for that kind of deployment scenario so we
had to find ways to make that work. So, one
example was that, a lot of OpenSocial gadgets
have URLs that are hard coded to access data
from a certain web service at a certain URL.
Well, we wanted our gadget developers to be
able to develop gadgets that can be installed
into any customer's instance of our software
and we'll contact back to that software to
get data. So we actually a developed kind
of a templating layer that sits on top of
the gadget specification and allows you to
embed macros within your gadget spec that
are transformed when you install that gadget
into a server, and so, for example, the URL
for that server or the OAT information for
that server. And so, it takes a generic gadget
and customizes it for the server that is installed
on.
>> How has providing an application with platform
helped your business?
>> MOORE: Well, all of our software has been
extensible pretty much since it was built.
We have a rich plug-in API for all of our
software and we've got a large ecosystem of
developers. Some of them are commercial developers
that sell products that work on top of our
software. Some of them are open source developers.
And we actually have made a lot of open source
plug-ins available ourselves so that people
can use this as a learning tool. So, even
though we're just kind of starting with the
OpenSocial stuff, our first OpenSocial implementation
is JIRA 4, which is going into beta this week.
We do kind of have a history of providing
an API layer for developers to build on our
software, and it's been incredible the innovation
that we've seen, people build on top of our
software and even entire businesses that are
based on building plug-ins for JIRA and Confluence.
So we're really excited about OpenSocial because
our softwares traditionally had Java APIs,
which is great if you're a Java developer.
Many of our customers are not. OpenSocial
allows you to build integrations based on
just HTMLs, CSS, JavaScript, simple Web technologies
that a lot of people understand. And so, it's
going to open the door to even more extension
and integration by a bigger audience of developers.
>> Do you have any advice for developers looking
to write OpenSocial apps?
>> MOORE: Well, developers who are writing
OpenSocial apps for our platform or gadgets
for our software are--we recommend that they
start with simple stuff and it's really a
good idea to get familiar with the gadget
technology by writing gadgets for iGoogle,
and then start to learn about how we provided
extensions on top of that for our own software.
A great resource that we just launched today
is a microsite on our website for OpenSocial,
and especially OpenSocial and the Enterprise.
If you go to www.atlassian.com/opensocial,
you can see videos, documentation, links to
resources for developers and end users. So
it's a great resource for anybody who's interested
in this technology.
>> Very cool. Very cool. So what's the most
lucrative OpenSocial container that you've
created?
>> MOORE: Well, most of what we've worked
with other than our own containers are Google's
containers. We're really excited especially
about the ability to embed gadgets in Gmail.
We think that's going to be really useful
for a lot of people who tend to live their
lives in email but want to see data from either
Atlassian or other applications juxtaposed
with their email and provide an easy way to
interact with a lot of different application
without having to leave their page. We're
also obviously really excited as is everybody
here about the Google Wave stuff. And we're
really interested in seeing if our gadgets
are going to work in that too, we hope so,
and I don't see why not.
>> Right. All right, Tim, I want to thank
you for your time today.
>> MOORE: Thank you.